[Music]
welcome back to Long crime daily and our
in-depth coverage of the unsealed
affidavit in the murder of the Idaho
four there is a lot of information that
we learned from that document that
really stopped everyone in their tracks
but there's also a lot of things that we
don't know law enforcement consider
Brian coburger as the sole perpetrator
in the murders but we still don't know
if the 28 year old Pennsylvania man has
anything to do with the college students
living in Idaho we do know that he was
studying at Washington State University
but exact connections haven't been made
earlier this week we learned that the
victim's parents are working with law
enforcement to try to connect those dots
the affidavit also mentions just one
piece of DNA at the crime scene
connecting back to co-burger the knife
sheath found on Madison Logan's bed with
the victims found brutally stabbed in
two separate locations there are
potentially more clues in the home on
Thursday we heard from trial consultant
Sunny Slaughter who emphasized the
importance of Justice this and also
patience in this type of case
Wharton as
it's important
for the public as much as it is for the
family
of Kaylee and Madison and zaina and
Ethan to know that Justice is working
in a process that will hopefully secure
them
not Justice in the sense that they will
ever forget but ensuring that whoever is
guilty of this crime is no longer out
and about to commit it again
so Brian we learned where the victims
were found but what the affidavit cut
short of doing was describing the
murders itself so what is missing there
yeah it's the autopsy report it's the
medical examiner's report uh we of
course know there it's a homicide it's
not an accident or something or a
natural death uh but what I'm looking
for and especially when you read that
first page and it says redacted just
before it gets into the two victims who
were found in the bathroom uh what do
these injuries look like who got more
injuries than the others did some
injuries look more brutal uh to some
victims than to others we already heard
some of that from some of the parents
describing the difference of the
injuries but I think if we look into the
medical examiner's report we're going to
get a lot more from the picture so far
the affidavit is telling us who and why
they believe it's who but I want to know
the how this all happened of course that
sheath gives us more information and
probably that's why we were led to
believe that this is that unique marine
or or military used weapon but I want to
know about the injuries that's going
going to give us a lot more information
and basically what you're saying Brian
is we don't have the why we don't have a
motive here and based on the information
Terry what is the motive here why would
he have done this do you think the
prosecution is going to explain the
motive that seems to me to be the
central question well you know I think
there might have been two separate
motives here or potential motives here
and the prosecution as you know doesn't
have to prove a motive but it's always
nice to be able to explain the story I
think the first motive could have been
the fact that he is obsessed with
criminology he has a masters in
criminology he's working towards his PhD
he studied under an expert serial killer
who knows how to define and to locate
serial killers not the fact that the
professor was a serial killer but he
knows how to find these people and so I
think it's clear that kohlberg is
obsessed with this and you know if
that's not the motive and I think that's
part of it he thought he could get away
with it but clearly he didn't he left
Brian talked about some of things that
he left behind in terms of his DNA the
shoe print the car all of these things
but if that's not the motive then it
could very well be the fact that one of
these women might have crossed his path
they probably didn't even know it
because we have seen that these other
people were talking about the fact that
co-burger just was arrogant and that he
got upset all the time if you turned him
down so I definitely think that that
could be an alternate second motive
there but we'll see if the prosecution
talks about it and we know that based on
the evidence he was possibly tracking
them so planning this it gives it just
another indication and all this Brian
Terry great job going through this
everyone thanks for joining us we will
see you next time as we discuss Justice
in America